[Music]
so today's lecture topic will be Arthur
goooo of Atlanta Georgia where I live
ray the best George in the world because
soon they'll both be Soviet Georgia if
you know what I mean
alright so I'll try to learn Russian for
next year's lectures or as you guys
would call it this year's lectures
alright now when I do chest the 21st
century as you all know I do it
correctly I look at games by someone who
was born in the 21st century right Arjun
your only hope I mean good job ok what
to do you if I ever find some of your
games you're in trouble
ok now Arthur goooo I've actually been
his coach twice at the world youth
and/or world cadet and there's not a lot
of games in the databases since he's 10
he's the highest rated ten-year-old in
the country approximately 20 to 65 plus
tax and in this year's world youth he
scored 8 or will cadet he scored 8 out
of 11 with 7 2 & 2 right Arjun 7 wins
two losses 2 draws how many points is
that a good answer right so he did ok he
tied for 4th I believe now the first
game we're going to look at extra we're
not going to look at any games we're
gonna look at positions from his games
Arthur's are very boring positional
players he's one of my favorite players
however since he's 8 9 10 years old as
games have a lot of sacrifices because
when you're 9 and you're a boring
positional player you still sacrifice
every move right Arjun yeah good answer
okay so here black has won the exchange
for a pawn and he's tripled on the
e-file okay in any weak player in this
room which is all of you would trade
Queens okay because you were taught by
someone who wasn't me that you should
trade when you're ahead okay as opposed
to the correct rule never trade okay and
here
it's getting crushed he's getting
checkmated and pinned and horrible and
even though I didn't know Arthur goooo
and he was only eight years old at the
very oldest he still played the move
Queen d2 with very complicated threats
which his seven-year-old opponent didn't
see in fact his opponent in this game
was also an American generally when it's
under 8 under 10 under 12 America okay
we do well then when it's under 14 16 18
I they forgot to show up okay now it's
not because we're terrible which would
be normal reason like 10 years ago that
was the reason but the reason now is our
best players don't show up they're like
yeah I'm too good for that tournament so
then instead we get Rufus in doofus and
then we're getting 50% the younger kids
they show up the older kids are like
yeah I want to show up I'm too good so
we have people like Kaden the truth
trove in Geoffrey Shawn and Sam Savion
and none of those and Roofing Li and
none of those players played in the
world youth this year on the other hand
Geoffrey Jean played in the world Junior
which is under 21 and at the age of 15
he won clear first
so he's the world junior champion if you
read chest life which would insinuate
you know how to read so I mean right
right Arjun you know how to read right
okay you like to pictures in chess life
the diagrams right so if you read chests
life this month's issue talks about
Geoffrey Zhang winning the world junior
because he wanted about six months ago
that's chess let gets to it several
months later when they think about it
and so our players who could win the
under 18 under 60 under 14 they don't
play in the tournament
so the only sections we can win are the
under 12 under 10 and under 8 now in the
under 12 this year we won gray and I
actually lectured about Nikhil Kumar I
think it was last week okay or as you
people know several weeks from now and
in the girls under 10 we just put the
video up today
Rochelle whoo although for some reason
Bensimon put one under tension that they
were under 12 everywhere
okay not not too bright Bensimon okay
he's not even here that's how Brady is
okay now in this position black has the
obvious threat which Arjun will explain
I gave you so much time Arjun come on
I take Saif to winning the Queen now
there's not a lot of good defenses to
that but probably something like king g1
would last an extra move then I would
play Queen e1 check and do it again okay
but instead white played for counter
play although I don't really see a good
move here and he played f6 totally
destroying blacks position blacks King
site is ruined so he resigned next game
nah I'm just kidding right Arjun okay
instead black continued his
eight-year-old threat what's that
someone argent again I'll do you Arjun
see that's why he knew the answer rook
takes f2 check and rookie - now the
truth hurts but you give a spite check
unlike you you give a sprite check
because I saw yeah there you go yeah
that see nice try trying to hide that
from me okay and I thought oh J did it
but he's right over there so yeah okay
exactly and then after every legal move
and he played one of them then why it's
like alright I give up what every legal
move won but he had to let him make one
than he resigned so that's typical in a
junior tournament you see some
relatively simple tactics ending the
game but more importantly Arthur showed
wisdom beyond his years by playing them
with Queen d2 because little kids are
taught to trade trade trade and he's
like wait a minute I'm winning
everything okay you could trade his
opponent's pieces without trading his
own okay so that was a fine game and the
lecture well it should be over but we'll
do one more okay and now this is also
from the same tournament and in fact I
was at this term I've been to the last
four worlds youth and or cadets maybe
five this was in Durban South Africa
right Arjun game and Durban South Africa
is well known for wide that's right
nothing very good
what's that who apartheid Durban Sutton
now oh yeah come on okay argit never
even heard of that oh yeah I believe you
okay Durban is the city in the world
with the most people of Indian descent
that's not in India over 1 million okay
so I'm not sure why that's important but
it is okay and then like after we left
from Durban then there was a lot of bad
stuff happening there
okay so we got there at the right time
okay so Arthur goes white and I like
this scheme because he plays very
suspiciously I like that
usually Arthur plays is boring as
possible that when his opponent falls
asleep he turns the clock take some
pieces off and the guy wakes up when
he's like I'm in ruins over here okay
but here Arthur tricked his opponent his
opponent played Bishop b4 pinning the
knight and the computer and slightly
prefers black see he cut all that other
stuff out they don't know I said Wyatt
okay anyway the reason it prefers black
is blacks pieces are all great painting
the knight on c3 this shabam b7 however
white has a very important Trump in this
position okay and it's not Melania okay
it's attacking the black king okay and
the attack doesn't work if you're
playing a super computer but this is the
Wold under 8 so it's guaranteed to work
okay so why play the most aggressive
move every move and black failed to
defend properly we have an
eight-year-old raising his hand you
unknown student they should take say 7
is checked but you missed King takes age
7 that's unfortunate
then I would move my King g8 Wow York we
went from d2 to h5 you're better than I
am
wow that's that's that's called a Doug
accurate yeah no it's it's true because
it is a Doug accurate that's Doug
defended that way once he
Queeny legally and he won no that's not
a joke that happened okay it's the only
get have ever seen Doug win so all right
now
Arthur goooo did what you did but he did
something legal that's why he's the top
ten-year-old in the country
he played 95 with obvious threats taking
on h7 in black played aged six bishop h7
check black played the best move they
still don't know I like Lee argent
raises his hand gay King AJ okay now
White's play is very suspicious and
doesn't work against a strong
Grandmaster or a computer but again this
is the world under eight so you got a
good chance
he played Knight f7 check now if King
takes 8 7 the queen is hanging now I
know Arthur pretty well he doesn't play
like this this is when he was young and
foolish 8 now he's 10 double digits now
he plays solid he doesn't Katie doesn't
taste good to him anymore double digits
you know they'd been married and
divorced twice since this game yeah ok
one of his kids is in college man the
other one on we won't talk about him
what a disappointment
ok so obviously King takes I'm sorry
obviously rook takes f7 and now the most
aggressive scary move of all time
Queen age 6 unfortunately it doesn't
work ok but black actually has to play a
good move and he's not going to do that
ok that you guys are like yet we know
what that's like
ok so White's threatening Bishop
everywhere winning bishop g6 Bishop e4
Bishop f5 everything wins ok and also
winning would be Queen h5 safe ok and so
black has to unpin his Jeep on but he
did so in the wrong way and in fact I
was giving a lesson say to one of my
students and I kept telling him chess
players are really bad at retreating
they don't like to retreat
that's why MVL is so good because he's
French all right why are you laughing
you didn't get that I origin what
workout 6 is what was played that's the
mistake that loses the game Knight f6
which is a retreat that wins the game
after Knight f6 the computer says Black
is winning not totally winning but a
little winning okay like +2 something
like that after rook f6 not only is
black losing but White has to play
perfect every move to win and he did
which isn't really fair playing on the
under 8 you shouldn't like play perfect
every move that's called the director or
something he played rook f6 okay
stopping all of White's threats except
it didn't stop all of White's threats
now of course White's playing for
checkmate that's why he sacrificed a
piece and has all his pieces near blacks
King when you watch let's say Carlsen
car Yaka and you fall asleep because
it's so boring and then you wake up it's
even more boring right and then you're
like why am i watching this instead go
to the under 8 tournament and watch
those games
if you fall asleep for a second and you
wake up there's like a 7 queen
difference so you got it you got a
really you got to focus on the under 8
games ok and white play the only winning
move which I'm sure you all find very
good somehow the highest rated player
knows the answer
Queen h5 and now the computer says
whites winning of course if somebody
like Ken West was black he would play
rook h6 after Queen 6 oh I can't believe
he did it again to me okay then that
actually would happen - right Arjun yeah
that would happen you know that what
happened right you know ken let's apply
wreckage 6 here he definitely would I
guarantee it
he's coming to my wedding tomorrow so
all that's explained that to him ok so
black played Knight f4 attacking the
White Queen a lot of you would play
discovered check but the Knights ace
Queen would solve that problem so he
took the night he played wreck h6 ken
west-style okay Bishop h6 King takes h7
and white only has one winning move but
it's pretty obvious Bishop to g5 check
and black loses his Queen and actually
after the move Queen age six white
played perfect every move which is
unfair and now black had a nice game but
now it looks like black didn't defend
his King too well so even when the
attack doesn't work in theory it works
in practice because Arjen you guys are
telling the wrong jokes didn't you get
the script I sent you know because
theory and practice are the same in
theory but not in practice okay I try to
remember yeah all right I mean I said
theory in practice you don't know that
one you come to all my lectures and you
take notes it's in your notes somewhere
okay I mean in theory it's in his notes
put out in practice all right
so Arthur wins hooray and his opponent
cries and I'm not kidding about that
either
yeah the world at the world youth and
world cadet the only question I ask my
students is that your opponent cry
fifty-fifty and what was my favorite
answer who remembers previous lectures
what was my favorite answer when I asked
that you that's just the usual answer I
had a much better answer than that the
game was about 30 moves and my students
said my opponent started crying I moved
12 and did it through the rest of the
game Annapolis and what's funny was it
was the last round so I was thinking was
the kid cried for 11 rounds what extra
round 11 you're like I won't cry anymore
like I've already lost six game there he
cried for the whole game Wow okay I gave
him I give him an extra treat that was
good okay because making your opponent
cry that's what chess is all about okay
now here's another game where Arthur got
pretty aggressive as you can see White's
positions pretty strong okay so black
play the obvious Bishop takes d3 now
unfortunately for black the bishop which
looks like an aggressive Bishop is
actually a defensive bishop we need to
defend g6 otherwise white will play
queen g6 so we don't have time for moves
like Bishop takes e4 okay and Arthur
noticed that and played rook f3
and said we want to take my night queen
g6 is a little risky he's like no I
don't think so let's let's save our
bishop okay
now the favorite move of Matt Larson and
Patrick wolf giving the answer away
white played I gave the answer way see
hold on I'm getting texts from Matt
Larson and Patrick wolf either right you
that's the favorite move of Matt Larson
no that's no rook takes out five who
know that's you know the Matt Larson
it's the only one he ever plays every
game you yeah man why does sudden like
g4 here g4 is good because the bishop
can't defend g6
however the bishop should defend g6 like
it really should okay so instead of
resigning black played rook a seven and
he's like alright I'll sack apiece but
my rook will come defend and what did
Emmanuel Lasker say I think Arjun was
there when he said it he said when you
see a good move look for a better one
okay and there's a picture of Lasker I
think right now somewhere yeah there is
right there okay and taking the bishop
is winning but he played a better move
which is strange for an eight-year-old
usually like Oh G for tacky division we
didn't move it and they start slobbering
on the board and you know you're going
to clean that up right instead white
play-doh move suggested earlier by the
class rook aged three and the truth
hurts you know you can't move your
bishop Bob g6 or stop Queen h8 made ya
tough to be black here but if you ever
have the black pieces don't let your
opponent have a pawn here the whole game
unless you're playing me nothin okay all
right and again they don't resign
because it's the underage so we get to
see some funny finishes okay Bishop
takes c6 now I showed this position to a
nice giri and he gave a perpetual he was
like oh boy
draw he was really he was really happy
right Arjun all right Arjun said right
that's a good answer
okay now I'm just kidding in each I'm
not kidding okay and
the draw that on each found he played
checkmate usually you don't see
checkmate because law and you should
never won a game so never seen checkmate
and and also people usually resign but
not only under a then you know we see
checkmate
so that really wasn't fair because my
engine said Arthur played perfect every
move when you're playing in the world
under eight your your opponent shouldn't
play any good moves okay and I'll tell
you a funny story about American parents
and probably parents all over the world
but Americans for sure because I'm the
American coach American parents that
take their kids to the World
Championship they expect their kids to
win okay that's how can got elected
their expectations are very suspicious
okay and they're like why didn't my kid
win the World Championship and I'm like
your kids like the fourth best player on
your block how's it going the World
Championship okay so when the kids do
win the world championship which does
happen we're all very impressed the
parents aren't so and of course my kid
won okay and when they don't win the
parents get really mad why did my could
not get 11 out of 11 and I'm like your
kids not from Vietnam that was the right
answer at one of the world youths in the
under 10 the kid got 11 out of 11 that
kid won yeah he made Fischer look bad
yeah okay so Arthur goooo who's a boring
positional player when he was 8 he was a
crazy wild attacking player and that
seemed to work well for him because
sometimes he played perfectly and he won
and sometimes he wasn't winning but his
opponents couldn't defend very
suspicious works in poker - okay his
poker game isn't that so efficient yet
all right now this is a more recent game
this game was played two months ago in
the world cadet that I was at in Georgia
and Arthur who was from Georgia right
Arjun yeah but it's a different Georgia
yeah okay you're less confused it used
to be there was one Soviet Georgia but
soon there'll be two okay and he won't
delete that joke because he won't get it
yeah okay so here his opponents
attacking him okay ridiculous
but his opponent didn't realize
something
his opponent iddyn realized that his
rating was 1,400 so Arthur Google was
not impressed okay maybe my Khan will be
impressed that's about it and white
played queen g4 with obvious threats now
everybody who knows me knows that I
espouse Queen and Bishop against Queen
and night and then everybody else is
like Queen and night and they move their
arms like this like Donkey Kong okay and
yeah that night's great on d2 whoo but
the dish about d5 okay and as you all
suspect the game ended very shortly in
checkmate black checkmate in white right
Arjen it's right so say yeah okay so
Queen g7 is a threat and so black played
g6 and now Queen g7 is not the threat
okay and then we played 94 now most
people would immediately play f5 forking
the Queen and night we call that doing a
ken west and then white plays Queen g6
check and you're like oh yeah
didn't see that okay now in this
position black has a big positional
advantage White has this terrible pawn
on c2 and if the pawn moves black is
going to take it and the pawns not
defended and White has no threat so
black played rook c8 and White was like
boom how do I defend that pawn rook C
one looks pretty stupid rook have to
looks pretty stupid my back rank is
empty and my opponent might eventually
play f5 so let's stop everything
no f5 no attacking c2 and f5 was played
you have to retreat to f2 if you go to
d2 you don't defend your C pawn man
White had a nice attack that he put all
his pieces back Queen c7 attacking not
only c2 but u f4 can't defend them both
so he defended one of them twice and now
white played the winning attack here Y
could resign White's down material is a
to pawn is hanging his knight on h3 is
trapped his kings in the corner his
works are terrible but instead he played
Knight g5
I check the winning sacrifice winning
for black and Arthur took it then he
checked King g8 and now white played the
move that allowed imminent mate Queen e5
threatening rookie che check Queen h8
check and then white realized he just
made a big mistake
although resigning would have been
quicker and actually he resigned before
his opponent moved and his move would
have been Queen G to mate and as the
kids in my kids class would say forking
the rooks yeah I would be like now the
king is attacked they would say and the
rook another kid would say and the other
rook and then another key would say end
the pawn on b2 yeah
and then some other key would say the
pawn on h2 yeah that would all happen -
even at home they're like yeah that's I
was thinking okay okay so instead of a
lion Queen g2 mate white instantly
resigned okay Manchester stuff if it's
white White's move White has a good
attack probably still losing yeah I
think if it's White's move he's still
losing I don't see him mate the King
runs out with you okay maple one so that
attack didn't work as well as Arthur's
attacks okay and last and not least this
was also played and this was in the last
tournament this was very late in the
tournament this is one of the last
rounds and this was a game where Arthur
got really lucky so he had a big
advantage and he threw it all away then
he won again
with tricks because Arjen yeah so after
Queen c'est CA the computer says it's
about equal it prefers white a little
bit okay and now this is very important
and you actually might learn something
of this is a chance for you to write
well you have obviously colored bishops
you want to be the one attacking and in
this position it's not clear who's
attacking it looks like blacks King is
safer than whites black has all of his
pawns in front of his King White's moved
all the pawns in front of his King his
King could get exposed you could imagine
black playing Queen h3 or Queen h1 and
whites came again a lot
so Arthur pulled out all the stops to
attack blacks King he played aged six
the computer is not impressed but he's
not playing a computer okay and if
you're black here like what do I do
about that
the computer plays the cold-blooded
what's the cold-blooded move what's that
yeah you got to take stuff if you're
cold-blooded okay I also got the right
answer when I give this lecture many
years ago from Rick James I was like
what's the right move and he raised his
hand and I said you and he said
cold-blooded and I was like exactly
right Arjen okay good all right so G
takes age six is equal black play G six
now that pawn still on H six if you had
taken it that it wouldn't be there okay
and here
Arthur missed a very good continuation
and I don't blame him okay in fact some
would say he missed an explosive
continuation you see four did you say
that - yeah see four he played Bishop d4
very suspicious game see four is very
interesting the idea is if you take with
a queen i play rook c3 and rook c8 check
and then you're not very happy so you
take with a bishop then you lose your
rook on d7 so the obvious move is arjun
Bishop c6 and now it seems like this
Queen was on the open C file and we
closed up that C felt pretty good so now
we play Queen c3 threatening Queen hear
me okay and the computer likes white
okay it's not dead loss but it's bad
okay instead he played the move Bishop
to d4 because he played four tricks and
his opponent fell for those tricks his
opponent played Bishop b4 which doesn't
lose but he's on the road to losing okay
it's an interesting Road a lot of
eight-year-olds go on that road okay but
hero's opponents 10 that's crazy
also it says world under 12 and was
definitely under 10
okay so and who won the world under ten
let's call on Arjun
now that was the girls under ten it's
the only kid I ever ever lecture about
ever you maka via
there you go okay and in fact Arthur
goooo drew maka they have in this
tournament all right so now your rook is
attacked so you should move it away
haha you fell for that okay instead
arthur tried to figure out a way to get
his queen to g7 he thought that would be
a better idea so what did he do
Arjun he moved his Queen somewhere III
II - nobody knows ke - Queen III is the
same now black should have been
suspicious about taking the rook since
he gets mated so when your opponent
sacrifices or blunders or loses an
exchange on purpose you should be
layaway - Bennett that work had a lot of
squares to go to and he intentionally
didn't move it away so let's figure this
out he didn't do a good job of figuring
it out and the reason was he thought
after Bishop takes which is the losing
move he could defend his bishop with
something like f5 and the computer says
White's slightly better Queen e5 he
thought he would play the move that I
say never play have six in fact you
better play f6 if you play King f8 I'll
play Queen h8 and take the Queen unsee
it
and I think in his mind he had a mental
block that after f6 white would play
Queen f6 which makes sense and after
Queen f6 black is okay because g7 is
protected by the rook the only threat is
Queen h8 but black could just move his
queen somewhere and after f6 Queen f6
white is not winning in fact I think
blacks winning after Queen f8 so f6
Queen f6 which was not play
it I think queen f8 is good okay then
Queen a Jay King f7 and okay blacks up a
rook so white better do something fast
and maybe there's other good news for
black and I think that's what he
analyzed f6 Queen f6 I'm okay but f6 not
only hangs the F pawn what else does it
hang the e pawn so he took that that's
much more annoying obviously rook f7
loses the Queen Queen takes Queen King
eight shades not very good because of
Bishop f6 check that's not good yeah
okay
so he realized all Queen e6
oops and you shouldn't miss the capture
and you shouldn't miss a check he should
miss both it's both King f8 s-- the only
move he resigned instead Queen f6 and
now we're going to win your Queen it
doesn't matter what you do unless you're
going to get mated somehow the way to
get mated you guys get made it a lot as
their way for black to get mated I don't
see way but there must be but okay every
other way allows Queen h8 and Queen
takes Queen so actually Bishop takes
rook just lost immediately and since his
opponent was 400 points higher rated and
obviously intentionally gave his rook
away you should be like hmm but people
don't do their like rook ah take the
rook and they took the rook and then
after here he still thought he was doing
well but it was Queen e6 actually
thought he was doing good until he saw
the weird al' video then he realized he
was doing well was he doing well no
terrible okay
and obviously instead of the move f6
what should black have played Bishop f1
always play Bishop f1 if I was white in
my opponent play Bishop f1 that move
might kill me that's the only way of
winning f6 I would expect but not Bishop
f1 right Arjen now think that one was
right I think that one was wrong okay so
that's Arthur goooo winning lots of
games before the age of 11 who else in
this room would do that oh yeah Arjen
right and so when Arjun gets to be a
high rated player like tomorrow right
then we'll do a
extra on your games you could actually
be here who was the last person in this
chess club who was here and I did a
lecture on them
Rochelle well she was here about a week
ago
yeah and I'll tell you guys a funny
story because the video went up today or
as far as you guys know two weeks ago
but for you guys it was today I made a
video Rochelle woo world champion she
got something from the state Congress
Senate of Alabama saying she's great and
when she got here she said oh yeah I
played in Kentucky last week I lost one
1800 to 1500 so the truth hurts there
our next couple of tournaments she beat
experts and masters so if you want to
play Rochelle woo I recommend being 1500
so if some of you gained 300 rating
points you're all set alright some of
you got that you and you showed her who
the boss was her right yeah so yeah
exactly
yeah that was some kind of night off
right the end that you guys like school
swished yeah well she's older than you
yeah all right that was chess of the
21st century and soon will be the 22nd
century then you'll give the lectures
right yeah maybe you think I'm gonna
give lectures but now leaving my head in
a jar if it's like Futurama
[Music]